- Hello. (clicks tongue)
- Are you ready?
- Hannah's amazing day out.
- So today Buzzfeed is at VidCon.
And we're going to
interview some top creators
to hear some of their VidCon experiences.
Let's do it. Let's go. Let's go.
- Hey guys, I'm Manny MUA.
- Hi, my name is Hannah Hart.
- Hey, I'm Colleen Ballinger.
- Hey everyone, my name is Patrick Starrr.
- It's Alicia Marie.
- I'm Rosanna Pansino.
- Hi, my name is Remi Cruz.
- The first time I went to VidCon,
it was at the bottom of a hotel.
This was maybe like
the second VidCon ever.
- I think my first one was bouncing from
food truck to food truck
finding ice cream, hotdogs.
- I just remember being really nervous,
being shocked that anyone knew who I was.
- People crowding you, swarming
you, taking photos with you.
I love it honestly, I
think it's freakin' great.
And I'm like bitch yes, I'm like, yeah.
- For me, I first started
coming as a community creator
and I remembered
specifically this one time
I was standing outside
and I saw Rebecca Black
and these other people were being like
ushered to the hotel across the street
and everybody was like mobbing them.
I was like, one day, that's gonna be me.
- I decided to do a scavenger hunt
with my fans through Snapchat.
So, I was like, okay go to this location
and you'll get a free beach ball.
Go to this location and
the final location was me.
They got to meet me.
And I didn't understand how
many fans I had at VidCon.
So, it caused like stampedes
and security got so mad at me.
I had to make a formal apology to VidCon,
I felt so bad.
- First year, I was not in any
way, shape, or form invited,
so I just kinda came, it was
actually really crazy for me.
I needed to get security
and VidCon was like,
What are you doing here?
Why are you doing this?
It was such a intense moment, I was like,
I don't know, I just wanted
to come and be part of it.
- Look, I don't remember what
happened the night before.
What I do remember, is that I woke up
and my pants were covered in
ranch and in the bath tub.
I wasn't wearing them. Ranch pants.
- I'm at the top of the
escalators and I hear
mad screaming and running, and
I was so scared for my life.
I turn around and I see
literally hundreds of people swarming.
It was Jack or Finn, one of
the twins, Jack and Finn.
That was my introduction to VidCon.
I was like, "Okay, I get what it is now."
- One of the most special
memories that I've had at VidCon
actually happened this morning.
I got to team up with Make a Wish,
and make a wish come true.
I met a young girl from Texas named Maddie
and we decorated cakes
together all morning.
We took pictures, we had a blast.
My heart is so happy right now
that I'm about to get emotional.
But this is a memory that
will last with me forever
and I hope she had a great
time as well 'cause I did.
- I think connecting with a community,
being actively social,
make a friend online,
make a friend in person, that
way you don't feel alone.
I think early on when I
started, I felt so alone.
I'm like, "I don't know what
to do. I'm a man in makeup."
And then I found other men in makeup.
Once you find your
niche or your community,
it'll make you feel a lot
more comfortable and grown.
- Consistency is key,
don't get discouraged
if you don't get views right away.
Yyou have to just keep
trekking on and keep doing it,
and stay consistent with your content.
- My advice to future creators
is honestly just to start.
I feel like a lot of
people get this weird thing
in their mind like, "I
don't have enough equipment,
or I don't have the best lighting.
I don't have the best camera,
or anything like that."
It's not about that,
it's literally just putting
your best foot forward.
- I feel like the biggest
thing is just to be yourself.
It took me years to really get
comfortable with the camera.
Before, I tried to be so perfect,
and no one wants to see
someone who's just perfect.
- Find your voice, have
fun, be consistent,
and don't put too much
pressure on yourself.
- People can see when you're doing YouTube
for the right reasons, so make content
that you would watch yourself.
- Create content that
you are passionate about.
If you love singing, sing.
If you love comedy, you serve that comedy.
Whatever you love, make content about it.
Because people are so
intuitive, they're so smart.
They know when you love what you're doing.
- Thanks for listening to me talk.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
Cool? Yay.
(rhythmic music)